[Music]
you sound like a woman to me but you
insist you are a man are you really who
you say you are are you really who you
say you are I've met few people in my
life ever who really feel genuine and
judgment-free and I would speak to that
being a great description of Savannah
and there's an openness and an accepting
nature that he that she has that makes
you feel like everything under the Sun
is okay it's funny you guys say that
because I took that away from the movie
with this openness and this theme of
gender politics and how we should be
accepting of everybody what did you guys
take away in that regard what do you
learn I guess yeah then it's a learning
process we all need to learn each other
and that it's not always an easy
immediate title or answer you know I
think it's easy to get a little
overwhelmed by the complexity of it of
that question and how unique it is to
every person but I think if you care
about other people and you're willing to
just take a little bit of time and go
what do you want me to call you I don't
know I mean you may look like one thing
to me but and you may having grown up
used to the idea that okay you're a boy
you're a girl cool he/she whatever it's
like if you care about moves to give it
up one more second and learn each other
and that's what I love about this movie
is that you know it's not presumptuous
in fact it's like leaning so far into
the vast depths of our you know
complexities which i think is really
beautiful Laura Dern and Kristen Stewart
starring JT Laroy out now it's based on
the true story and memoir of Savannah
canoe Kristen play Savannah who famously
pretended to be JT for her sister-in-law
when I first saw you might end up like
him huh I was lucky enough to have
Savannah once said every day she was
here every single day
yeah and also completely at my disposal
if I ever needed to call her for
anything
being able to enlighten people to sort
of that perspective and experience is
interesting because it's also a story
that a lot of people feel close to so it
was nice to sort of unveil somebody
standing someone you know barely lit at
the center of something really really
really bright and crazy next up Kristen
will star in the Charlie's Angels reboot
what do you think is the biggest
difference with this reboot and this
retelling probably just that it takes
place in a different year I think
there's really the same kind of
sense of camaraderie and it's fun and
kind of weird like girls when they're
together and hanging out and laughing
with each other or weirdos and we're all
definitely like weirdos together but at
the same time I think it has this kind
of grounded nature that we would need it
the only reason to remake that movie
right now because the other ones are so
great and I watch them growing up I
still I watch them again for making the
new ones and they are hilarious and I
still love those girls and they stand
and so the only reason to do it again
basically would be to make it so the
organization is expanded you know
there's a lot of us there's not just
three of us there are many more women in
this network of support it's still funny
and we still jump around and like hit
people but that's like the mission
statement seems strong it seems like it
has a reason
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]